mêmes journalistes qu'il y a quelques
jours me disait quand j'arrivais dans
une réunion
vous y croyez encore me disent
maintenant oh là là mais jusqu'où ça va
aller votre campagne
paris a une très grosse ambiguïté dans
cette espèce d'effet de mode qui le
concernerait par opposition à nicolas
sarkozy je suis désolé qu'ils étaient
ensemble et ensemble ils ont ils ont
commis des erreurs il prend des points
acquis à juppé mois sarkozy
je pense qu'il en prend aux deux je
pense qu'il en prend aussi à bruno le
maire
dimanche prochain il faut choisir
l'audace est pas la sécurité
fa le repli sur soi pas de retour en
arrière vous savez les sondeurs et nous
ferons quoi chaque fois comme par hasard
les choses se resserrent toujours
toujours à la dernière seconde
l'accusation est direct sont des tours
dont la vidéo ziad takeddine indique
qu'il a remis à nicolas sarkozy lui même
une valise pleine de billets un million
et demi d'euros en provenance de libye
début 2007
je veux être le candidat de toutes ces
familles qui ont été matraquées depuis
la première minute de ce quinquennat
agonisant qui n'aiment pas les familles
est ce que monsieur sarkozy 7 pourquoi
vous vous déposez cette valise est ce
qu'il est au courant de ce qui est à
l'intérieur ça franchement j'ai été bien
sûr depuis quelques temps c'est bien
normal
je concentre sur moi toutes les attaques
celles de mes adversaires et pas que
qu'est ce que ça vous inquiétez derniers
sondages
tu sais ce monsieur m'a déjà demandé
s'il va déjà demander c'est pour dire du
sérieux que ces questions si ça me
gênait des travaux je trouve que c'est
sans doute un humoriste et bien si leurs
auteurs croient me déstabiliser ils se
trompent droit dans des bas que j'ai été
droit dans mes bottes je resterai dans
le panorama de ceux qui se présentent à
droite comme à gauche à gauche on ne
sait pas encore
et bien c'est alain juppé et qui a le
meilleur profil prix aussi a fait salle
comble au zénith de paris hier soir
alain juppé est en pleine forme j'ai la
pêche super pêche d'alain juppé mais
aussi les frites de nicolas sarkozy qui
font leur grand retour dans le débat est
l'occasion de dire je trouve ça aussi
déséquilibré comme menu que le programme
du candidat qu'il a mis en avant frais
manuel macron candidat à la
présidentielle selon nos informations
l'ancien ministre de l'économie va
annoncer sa candidature pour 2017 demain
matin parties ont la corde sa signature
à emmanuel macron abbaoui bas à partir
de là on est on est en dehors du parti
socialiste voit ça paraît normal tout ça
oui
pour l'instant c'est un peu le candidat
plexiglas on voit au travers
donc on attend de voir s'il va y avoir
un contenu parce que ce ne peut pas être
que la nouveauté pour la nouveauté
bien que je ne ferai pas de commentaire
sur ce qu'est une possible je vous dire
ce que je ressens en période de grand
danger
on ne peut pas se payer le luxe de
l'inexpérience et de la naïveté d'un jeu
c'est le rassemblement c'est la cohésion
la gauche est divisée
et bien si elle n'est pas rassembler
elle ne pourra pas être au rendez vous